buonasera ho vissuto quasi quattro anni
a roma viaggia spesso per lavoro sono
più più più volte a milano fuori città
che qui e ai speak english white well
ma se vi chiedesse adesso dopo pochi
secondi gli dove sono beh non avreste
dubbi nel dire vabbè se napoletano la
nostra cadenza dialettale nostro accento
è una delle cose più difficili da
nascondere o da eliminare
c'è gente che paga paga soldi per
eliminare il suo accento per nascondere
la sua cadenza io del mio accento vado
fiero ne vado fiero perché mi ricorda da
dove sono venuto quindi mi tiene
ancorato alle mie radici e ne vado fiero
perché mi dà la giusta dimensione di
dove sono arrivato figurale miani ma non
è del mio accento che voglio parlarvi
stasera o almeno non solo di quello sono
nato nel 1981 anno di nascita di
personaggi del calibro di beyoncè zlatan
ibrahimovic
elijah wood frodo per gli amici e zack
and son degli hanson
ecco se non ricordate chi erano gli
hanson forze siamo di due generazioni
diverse
la mia generazione è stata definita e
svariati modi millennio hicks generation
y generation a seconda dell'anno in cui
si fa fallire uno a iniziare l'altra
next generation netgear action ma anche
generazione di fannulloni di bamboccioni
o come amato definirci un ex ministro
della repubblica generazione giusy
schizzinosa ma anche viziati pigri
svogliati scansafatiche insomma una
generazione smarrita ebbene la prima
cosa che ci tengo a dirvi stasera è che
io credo esattamente il contrario io
sono fermamente convinto che la mia
generazione della nostra generazione sia
una generazione fondamentale per non
smarrirci tutti ma facciamo un passo
indietro prima di noi quelli che sono
stati definiti i baby boomers
i nativi analogici come ama definirli o
i nati tra la mia prima metà degli anni
quaranta e la prima metà degli anni
sessanta i vari steve jobs bill gates
richard branson e donald trump si donald
trump è il nuovo che avanza degli stati
uniti ma anche vittorio basile maria
scarcello mia mamma e mio padre che pur
essendo infinitamente meno ricchi dei
personaggi precedenti hanno arricchito
di molto la mia vita e di questo li
ringrazio
facciamo un passo avanti dopo di noi i
cosiddetti nativi digitali e quando
parla di nativi digitali mi riferisco in
particolare a quelli puri tra virgolette
i nati post napster i nati dal 2000 in
poi la cosiddetta generazione always on
i vari figli dei pit dei cruise day
beckham dei carter beyoncé jesi e anche
ovviamente i figli di basile i miei
figli mattia alessia che pur avendo
genitori infinitamente meno famosi di
quelli precedenti sono comunque delle
piccole star ma io sono un po di parto
ebbene la differenza fondamentale
secondo me tra queste generazioni sta
proprio nel fatto nel come utilizzano o
non utilizzano le tecnologie digitali
del fatto dell'essere nati prima o dopo
quella che viene definita rivoluzione
digitale
l'evoluzione digitale il cui inizio si
attesta intorno al 1984 quindi tre anni
dopo la nascita quando alan kay iniziò a
parlare di informatica personale
a me non piace tanto il termine
rivoluzione preferisco il termine
evoluzione o il termine e potenziamento
digitale o meglio ancora preferisco
parlare di continuità nel cambiamento
sì perché sono convinto che il digitale
ha portato tanta novità tante cose nuove
ma fondamentalmente non è venuto a
sconvolgere niente è venuto
semplicemente a potenziare ea portare
all'ennesima potenza quello che già
esisteva vi faccio un esempio se prima
il sabato sera uscivamo andavamo in
discoteca per fare a chi apparsa a
trovare una persona con cui passare una
serata è una splendida notte magari
adesso esistono strumenti come questo
venga of friends venga offeso che poi
avuto un po di problemi è dovuto
rinominarsi in da un'app venga senza
funziona così tu sai comodamente seduto
sul divano a casa tua collega il tuo
account facebook
i tuoi amici facebook scegli l'amico all
amica con cui vorresti passare una
fantastica serata e una magica notte e
ci clicchi sopra
ovviamente non avviene nulla attualmente
sede potenziamento di una grossa figura
di m e nient'altro
ma se la persona che hai scelto dall
altra parte reciprocamente scegliete
allora si attiva lo scambio e poi bang
france ok non è nulla c'è è un
potenziamento nulla di non avere
variante tecnologica di fare anche a
panza di quello che facevamo prima
altro esempio pepper ap tedesca che
mette in collegamento i professionisti
del sesso e i clienti il mestiere più
antico del mondo potenziamento
continuità nel cambiamento potenziamento
di qualcosa che già esisteva e di
esempio potrei farne altri per esempio
ah scusate triste assurdo questa cosa
oppure comodo naturale ovvio
la differenza sta tutta qui se io
racconto a mia mamma di peppe di beni o
france mia mamma impazzisce mi diceva
una cosa triste assurda invece miei
figli probabilmente la giudicheranno una
cosa naturale poi la utilizzeranno meno
non sto giudicando questo ma per loro
sanno cosa ovvia normale
altro esempio fruizione di contenuti
musica quando scivole pd il cantante
preferito il mio padre mio pareti più
andava nel negozio andava comprava il
disco in vinile lo metteva lì e lo
consumava furia ad ascoltarlo ascoltarlo
ascoltarlo ascoltarlo per settimane oggi
i miei nipoti miei figli probabilmente
spingeranno ancora più avanti
ascoltano 150 200 pezzi al giorno su
spotify senza finire nessuno di questi è
passando da un genere all'altro diverso
sì ma sempre di fruizione di musica
parliamo
altro esempio espressione delle idee i
miei genitori quando dovevano
confrontarsi esprimere le loro idee
andavano in piazza andavano al bar lo
facevano faccia a faccia oggi si discute
sui social oggi piuttosto che pensare a
cose perché lo voglio dire si pensa a
come devo dire quella cosa che immagina
già socio che video sassoso perché
queste questa mia idea questo pensiero
arrivi a più persone possibili ma
parliamo sempre di espressioni di idee e
ancora mio nipote ha imparato a parlare
inglese
praticamente guardando video musicali su
youtube
questa cosa per mia mamma è
inconcepibile
perché lei abituata ai manuali
istruzione ai bugiardi e medicinali ai
corsi per imparare le cose lontanissima
dai concetti di learning by doing o di
imparare divertendosi hardman ma
parliamo comunque di apprendimento
guardate gli esempi potrei far bene
tanti ma non voglio analizzare la
questione quello che ci tengo a dirvi è
che secondo me se oggi ci sono delle
incomprensioni se oggi ci sono dei non
ti capisco o non mi capisce non puoi
capirmi
e perché ci stiamo perdendo dei pezzi di
questa continuità nel cambiamento
chi può riprendere questi pensi e questa
la domanda che voglio pormi con questa
sera marc prensky uno studioso
imprenditore americano il primo ad aver
dato la definizione di nativi digitali
ha dato anche un altra definizione
quella di immigrati digitali per freschi
gli immigrati digitali sono quelli che
pur non essendo nati nell'era digitale
a un certo punto ne sono rimasti
affascinati hanno incominciato a
utilizzare le tecnologie digitali
ecco france chi dice che l'immigrato
anche se inizia a utilizzare bene il
linguaggio digitale comunque rimane con
quell'accento un po analogico quel piede
nel passato lo stampare la mail per
leggerlo chiamare il collega per dirgli
ti ho mandato una mail
ok e freschi da un'accezione negativa
questa cento ecco la seconda cosa che ci
tengo a dirvi stasera è che secondo me
questo accento esattamente come la cento
di cui ho parlato all'inizio quello
dialettale è un accento di cui dobbiamo
andare fieri e anzi dico di più secondo
me questo e l'accento che può aiutare a
risolvere alcuni conflitti generazionali
quelli di cui ho parlato prima
oggi viviamo a cavallo tra due diversi
online e offline non tutti passiamo da
una parte all'altra ma è lo flyin spesso
viene definito il mondo reale
questa definizione però va via via ad
essere meno adatta pensateci cosa ero
qual era il mondo reale per mio padre
cos'è o qual è il mondo reale per me
cosa sarà o quale sarà il mondo reale
per i miei figli
bauman ci invita a fare molta attenzione
alla spaccatura tra online e offline
perché questa spaccatura è rischiosa
perché induce paura del diverso
dell'altro
i nativi analogici vivevano in un mondo
totalmente offline per questo hanno
paura nel mondo online i nativi digitali
vivono immersi 24 su 24 nel mondo online
e per questo mal digeriscono alcune cose
del mondo offline
e come se non percorso da un punto a un
punto ci sia nativi digitali canali
analogici si siano persi si fossero
persi il punto b quello di mezzo perché
i nativi analogici si sono persi la
conoscenza utili a comprendere il
cambiamento mentre i nativi digitali si
sono persi la memoria il percorso che
abbiamo compiuto la continuità appunto
per cui siamo arrivati a dove siamo oggi
bene la terza cosa che voglio dire di
stasera quella più importante di tutti
ecco quel punto b siamo noi siamo noi
che siamo madrelingua analogici ma
parliamo digitale fluente siamo noi del
nostro accento da immigrati che dobbiamo
metterci in mezzo a questi mondi e fare
da interpreti interpretare questi
linguaggi e permettere agli uni di
comprendere gli altri e dagli altri a
prendere quello che gli manca per
completarsi prima di questo tetto è
parlato con un po di amici professori
universitari esperti confrontandomi su
questa questione è venuto fuori quello
che per adesso è un punto di incontro di
discussione interpreti digitali perché
siamo convinti che bisogna spiegare la
vita analogica nativi digitali spiegare
la vita digitale a natì pedagogici e che
a farlo dobbiamo essere proprio noi
iniziative del genere ce ne sono già
state google messe in piedi alcune
assolombarda altre il limite grosso che
ho trovato in queste iniziative è che il
problema viene approcciato sempre con la
lente dell'uno o dell'altro mondo
guardandolo da un punto dall'altro
portiamo gli studenti nelle scuole a
insegnare portiamo gli studenti dei
pensionati in serie a usare le
tecnologie digitali oppure consiglia
portiamo i pensionati nelle scuole a
fargli capire quanto importante il mondo
offline mai da tutte e due le parti e
soprattutto sempre usando un linguaggio
e delle parole propria dell'uno o
dell'altro mondo a discapito dell'altro
a proposito di parole voglio far vedere
un pezzettino di uno short film di
daniel mercadante del collettivo e averi
non che impazzava online nel 2010 con
questi short molto belli che si intitola
proprio words
tra generazioni spesso ci diciamo tante
parole
i genitori ne dicono i figli per il loro
bene i figli ne dicono i genitori per la
loro libertà
il problema è che a volte le parole non
servono o meglio dovremmo imparare a
dargli la giusta connotazione a capire
come si vedeva nel video che diciamo
tanto anche senza dire la rete e il
digitale internet avrebbero dovuto
facilitare gli scambi tra generazioni
questa contaminazione e invece non
sembrano farlo e responsabile a me siamo
noi della generazione di mezzo
l'economista brasiliana lay line come
raccontava anche marco serra italiano al
target decs pechino di qualche mese fa
sostiene che esistono tre tipi di futuri
futuri probabili futuri possibili futuri
desiderabili un futuro probabile è
quello che ci accade senza che noi
facciamo nulla senza il nostro
intervento la nostra volontà un futuro
possibile a una scenario più ampio di un
futuro probabile ma non dipende ancora
la nostra volontà
in futuro desiderabile invece è quello
che ci impegniamo a raggiungere con
tutte le nostre forze ha bisogno di un
obiettivo di un progetto di risorse di
impegno e anche di una buona dose di
fortuna
ecco a noi tutti immigrati digitali
stasera voglio dire che abbiamo davanti
questi tre tipi di futuro
probabilmente se non faremo nulla la
generazione dei nativi analogici si
estinguerà finirà senza aver trasmesso
ai nativi digitali la memoria necessaria
a capire dove siamo arrivati perché ci
siamo arrivati e senza aver ricevuto da
loro la conoscenza utile a comprendere
il cambiamento che stiamo vivendo e noi
resteremo i fannulloni e chiusi i
bamboccioni probabile che accada
qualcosa di diverso sì ma chi può dire
se è meglio peggio che non voglio stare
con le mani in mano ad aspettare
io voglio desiderare il futuro mio e dei
miei genitori e dei miei figli e voglio
farlo insieme a chiunque di voi voglio
farlo insieme a me come dice che la
verità non lo so penso a spazi di
ricerca di contaminazione di
sperimentazione tra generazioni che ci
aiutino a trovare un linguaggio
condiviso il misto tra analogico e
digitale che serve a comprenderci a
superare le incomprensioni
i fraintendimenti quello di cui sono
certo però che abbiamo la responsabilità
di farlo
esso anche come dobbiamo farlo con un
atteggiamento acritico professionale
integro un po come gli interpreti a una
conferenza internazionale
pensateci gli interpreti alle conferenze
internazionali sono lì per assicurare la
correttezza del dibattito che si sta
svolgendo la fedeltà al dibattito che si
sta svolgendo devono prepararsi prima
sugli argomenti delle riunioni che
andranno in tre pedane sui linguaggi sui
temi sulla terminologia che si andrà a
utilizzare devono essere pronti a
reagire istantaneamente a cambiamenti
che avvengono in quella sede devono
essere pronti a lavorare in un ambiente
multiculturale di non essere reattivi
ecco io tra una tv analogici e digitali
prima ancora che immigrato voglio essere
un interprete che dite si
accontenteranno del mio accento grazie